the explosive third season finale of you
has everything from roast dinners to die
for to extreme cage therapy and a big
twist setting up season four yippie kai
movie lovers i'm jan and in this video
i'm breaking down all the things you
might have missed in the ending of you
season 3 the clues that predicted the
shocking conclusion and what the future
holds for joe we'll be talking spoilers
so take care if you're not all caught up
the fact that joe would end up
permanently severing his and his son's
ties with love in the finale was
foreshadowed all the way back in the
opening scene of the season where he cut
the umbilical cord between love and baby
henry and just an episode later it was
also hinted at by the couple's therapist
who had no idea of the serial killer she
had for clients neither one of you is
going to kill your spouse you're many
things but you are not
murderers the problems in joe and love's
marriage come to a head in the final
episode when she serves in roast chicken
which she figured out was his favorite
meal on their very first night out
together perfect bite perfect that was
also the night that joe found out about
love's dead husband and when they both
discovered how alike they were fast
forward to now were it's the dying days
of their relationship and roast chicken
and dead husband discussion are back on
the menu with love admitting to killing
her first spouse by accident when she
tried to temporarily paralyze him with
aconite to stop him from leaving her and
now it's joe's turn as he unwittingly
grabs a poison laced carving knife that
love set to trap him this time i'm
letting it absorb through the skin none
of this would be happening if you hadn't
grabbed a weapon in their twisted
obsession love and joe are almost mirror
images of each other so she realized
he'd go for the knife love knows me
better than anyone ever has i'm starting
to understand why that's so terrifying
by the way notice how love used a glove
to handle the carving knife before this
so that she wouldn't get the poison on
her own hand love's choice of aconite
which is commonly known as wolfsbane has
an extra level of meaning in this show
because the word wolf used to be part of
her and joe's special love language i
love you is there another word we can
use i wolf you i wolf you too and in
season three when joe and love are
struggling to enjoy sex together he
bemoans the fact they don't say i wolf
you anymore you've been domesticated i
will see you wolf or dog on a leash
there were also a few possible hints in
season two towards love's eventual use
of wolf spain on joe when she playfully
attacked him with a toy wolf a gesture
that also signaled her ponchon for
slashing her victim's throats and there
was also the real wolf the quinn's
brought to the wellness weekend which
snarled aggressively at joe
interestingly after marienne's advice to
listen to the tiny voice in her own head
love realizes just how many things are
wrong in her relationship i mean you
guess lit me so hard i'm not the problem
my husband is the problem and she
decides to cut her losses and goes to
kill joe with the same cut-throat mo she
used on most of her previous victims but
joe's already turned the tables on his
mirror image wife she just doesn't
realize she's been hoisted by her own
batard until he stabs her in the leg
with a syringe full of her own deadly
wolf spain our love language is violence
and in a little visual gag the jar of
poison joe pulled the wolf spain from
was labelled dye sample oh and despite
joe's unfavorable views of the madre
linda dads when he first meets them the
haze of narcissistic delusion that just
the right biohack you'll live forever
it's actually biohacking that saves his
life in the end by the way notice that
joe doesn't eat anything before he sees
love eat because he was already worried
about being poisoned a call back to when
love brought him muffins after trapping
him in his cage in season two no poison
joe given their one-upmanship with
poisonous wolfbane love and joe have
certainly brought very literal meaning
to the term toxic relationship
joe's recipe for a successful getaway
involves cooking up a salacious story to
keep everyone's minds occupied with
juicy details the aim being to stop them
asking awkward questions about how true
it is and he certainly knows his
audience because the people of madrid
linda love to gossip and are more
interested in manufactured reality than
reality itself for the public the brand
is conventional monogamy so joe
sprinkles just enough believable
information into the taylor concocks cue
him preparing a chicken pot pie using
against love the fact that she's a
trained pastry chef and well known as
the town's baker and it's all somewhat
ironic that part of joe ends up in
love's chicken pie given that chicken
was his perfect bite in their early
loved up days and their wedding vows
even included pastry you said you would
always share a bite of your pastry with
me no matter what intriguingly joe's
final plan was foreshadowed in the
opening episode this isn't some german
fairy tale where a witch keeps me locked
up till it's time to eat me that's a
shout out to hansel and gretel where the
witch who plans to eat the children is
outwitted by them and ends up dying in
her own fiery oven on top of that the
way joe turns love into a legendary
figure akin to the baker who made murder
victims into meat pies and sweeney todd
the mrs lovett of madre linda is
especially apt because in the musical
version of that story todd burns the
baker mrs lovett to death after shoving
her into an oven while in the original
story he kills her with poison and let's
not forget the little box of gruesome
mementos that joe leaves at love's side
as well as gil's driver's license
there's a bunch of teeth probably
natalie's we know joe removed them to
avoid dental records as he did with
benji and remember he wouldn't tell love
what he'd done with them i just don't
want to find them in a hidey hole in my
house you won't
it's safer if you don't know given that
earlier in the same episode love refused
to tell joe what she'd done with candace
and delilah's bodies it's safer if you
don't know i imagine joe kept the teeth
in case love tried pinning those season
two deaths on him after all he admits to
hanging on to another of natalie's
possessions for similar reasons and
suggests using that to frame matthew for
her murder
with all the evidence in place to frame
his dead wife joe sets the house on fire
to ensure the crime scenes damaged
enough to make the faked murder suicide
more plausible he leaves the burning
building to go in search of marianne
exactly as was foreshadowed several
episodes earlier for you marion i will
walk through fire there were also some
other early hints that telegraphed how
love would end up getting the blame for
torching the house all you ever showed
me was to get the prince built a castle
and then burn it out of the ground and
then there was love's mother dotty who
set light to her own vineyard during a
bitter divorce which would doubtless
lead the town gossips to say like mother
like daughter and at the library gala
when joe was panicking about love and
marianne meeting up his inner monologue
predicted the events of the final
episode i should orchestrate a disaster
in the kitchen truck turn up the oven
scorch the quail it's like i'm watching
my own execution perhaps influenced by
love's dying words
joe realizes he might not be a good
father and if he stays he'll be locked
up as her accomplice setting his son on
the same damaging path as himself so he
tearfully leaves his baby with dante and
lansing and henry is in safe caring
hands instead of dottie's unstable
sozzled ones or the lonely potentially
bullying hands of a group home so
hopefully for henry joe's broken the
harmful cycle set in motion by his own
parents
at the start of the finale love told
kiki and co they were a bunch of scandal
hungry crows the no amount of feasting
on other people's sorrows is gonna make
your lives less hollow but by the end of
the episode those same people are having
a really good go at proving love wrong
as they dine out on her misery building
businesses profiting off her death from
the jokey pseudo-feminist rebrand of
their bakery targeted more at selling
insta-worthy t-shirts than good quality
food like love did yelp suggests the
scones are just okay to the at-home test
for poison inspired by her use of toxic
wolf spain to a self-help bestseller
about kidnapping and caging caged a
radical couple's therapy technique as
for marianne she takes love's advice to
get away from joe leaving no number or a
dress behind due to her ex-husband she
already knew the dangers of toxic
relationships i promised myself my next
relationship would be aboveforward and
honest and though she'd pushed it aside
she'd had a bad feeling in her gut about
joe something in me knew that it was too
good to be true in fact her words in
that moment echo beck's view of joe in
the season one finale and you knew
somewhere deep it was too good to be
true unlike joe who believes in fairy
tales how do i make you see i could be
your happily ever after marianne doesn't
believe in damsels in distress instead
her favorite fairy tale is jack and the
beanstalk jack was a little badass i
wanted to be him still princesses so
given all that then when joe wonders did
you pity me when you read what happened
did it erase the fear she planted do you
still think about us i imagine
marianne's answer would be a big fat no
the season ends with joe taking his
creepy stalking act on the international
road i have to believe our paths are
destined to cross again paris is his
destination of choice as marienne's
originally from there and she told him
during her custody battle that's where
she'd run to with her daughter if she
thought her ex-husband wouldn't find
them and spend their days drawing
outside sakakura though marianne
mentions the famous basilica of sacre
coeur that's not where we see joe in the
final scene he's actually here a
location the show likely chose to
recreate as is fantastic views of the
eiffel tower which immediately signals
to viewers where joe is the name of the
cafe is le chaser solitaire which
translates into english as the lone
hunter brilliantly fitting for joe
goldberg and his continued solo predator
activities i think i'm meant to be a
lone wolf it does feel kind of ironic
that after joe lied about his ex candice
leaving him and running off to europe
that's what seemingly has actually
happened with marianne this isn't the
first time that paris has popped up on
the show as a place to get away and
start fresh either peach wanted beck to
move there with her and live it her
parents flat paris could be a new
beginning for the both of us and after
caging delilah in season two joe
suggested the french capital to love as
a place to wipe the slate clean what if
we leave together start over you could
finish cooking school in paris by the
way those jingling bells on the cafe
door are meant to make us think of beck
joe's first main infatuation in the
series which in many ways indicates he's
right back where he started yes he's in
a new city a new country even but he's
still the same old joe the barista may
call him nick a sign that he's taken on
a new identity for this next chapter but
joe already has form for this in la he
kidnapped will bettelheim and stole his
identity though he did eventually free
him and they kept in contact so maybe
will helped him out with a fake passport
to get out of the us and perhaps joe
picked the name nick subconsciously
thinking of dr nicki the man he falsely
framed to the murderer beck in new york
although joe's delusional antics in you
are intriguing to watch in real life to
keep our personal details away from
creeps and snoopers like him we all need
to improve our online security and a
crucial part of keeping your online life
private is using a vpn whenever you're
online if you're using public wi-fi like
in a coffee shop you're especially at
risk from hackers who can break into
your connection and access any personal
data being transmitted using a quality
virtual private network on your mobile
devices like your phone and laptop will
make sure you're protected against these
threats which is why at flicks in the
city we recommend nordvpn a virtual
private network creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
a vpn server stopping your internet
service provider or any other agencies
from tracking you online reading your
emails and private messages or seeing
what websites you're visiting nord has
an incredibly intuitive interface which
lets you connect up to six devices at
the same time so you can use it on your
computers at home as well as phones
tablets and laptops whenever you're out
and unlike free vpns nord is incredibly
fast with over 5000 servers in over 60
countries worldwide nord is also great
at helping you access any content which
may be restricted in your region you
simply connect to a server in another
country and then browse the internet as
if you were there for a limited time all
our viewers can grab a very special
offer of a huge 73 of a two-year plan
plus four bonus months for free just
visit
nordvpn.comflix or go to the link in the
video description to get the offer or
use coupon code flicks when you check
out so what did you think of season
three of you and how it ended and what's
in store for joe next leave your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below coming up for more you videos with
all the easter eggs you missed in season
3 and more season 4 theories you can tap
here to watch those and if you enjoyed
this then a thumbs up and a share are
hugely appreciated thanks for watching
and see you next time yippie kay movie
lovers